but Fancy's not losing his hair the way
that Carlos is he's like the Mexican
Larry David he's like Luis David
[Laughter]
he is and Carlos is uh
what are you doing
keep Carlos's name out of your [__]
mouth
dude it was like a Mexican Larry David
joke I was Camp Carlos's name out of
your [__] mouth okay dude if you
didn't see the Oscars Chris Rock got
himself in a hairy situation he shined a
light on female alopecia while Jada's
head shined a light on everything else
Chris was making fun of Jada's Baldi but
seriously how is Will supposed to get
turned on if she has a woman's haircut
now I'm not saying that he's gay he
likes women specifically ones that swim
for pen holy [__]
that's the first time will fondled
another man to make Jada happy okay
struck Chris Rock was actually a
metaphor for his relationship with Jada
open when he wanted it to be closed but
let's be honest last night Will Smith
looked like he was from the Streets of
Philadelphia and Jada looked like she
was from the movie
after all that drama Will Smith still
took home an Oscar I'm talking about the
award not a Mexican guy to [__] his wife
while he walks in the corner of the case
right he went and he cracked the joke
will was laughing that phony ass laugh
and he went yeah that [__] ain't funny
[Applause]
I think she put a spell on that [__]
she had a Men In Black Voodoo Doll
underneath her chair
cause that [__] out of nowhere
he just changed his whole [__] up so we
saw her roll our eyes up in her head but
that ain't what she did she put a spell
on him
thank you
and the Ghost of Tupac Shakur possessed
Will Smith's body let me see [__] we're
sorry
even the way the [__] walked back to
the seat that wasn't Will's wall and
there that was Tupac walk [__]
I know that duck leg walk [__]
definitely walk that's I worked with
Tupac that is burning from Above the Rim
[__] got out the Ranger
[Applause]
that is Bishop from juice [__] I know
that duck leg walk
look at me even the way he was screaming
from his seat all ignorant and [__] like
Tupac on one of his disc records keep my
wife stirring out your [__]
mind
that [__] sound like first off East Side
[__] click the claim
I want to let you know that there is a a
definitive blueprint
that you can follow
to achieve success
prosperity
longevity and peace of mind
it's a blueprint and I followed it my
whole career it's very simple there's
three things you just do these three
things
pay your taxes
mind your business
and keep Will Smith's wife's name
yesterday Will Smith resigned from The
Academy of Motion Pictures Arts and
Sciences he wasn't going to but then
Jada gave him that look
I'm gonna say some horrible [__] up here
I should warn you guys now but you know
just don't Will Smith me you know
yeah yeah that was ugly huh holy [__] I
think we should change the term from
Karen to Jada uh-huh yeah
yeah oh yeah
yeah
man that was wild [__] left on
television next year the option is going
to be produced by Dana White yeah
even Putin was watching that [__] going
geez a little violent over there huh
holy hell
I still think it's weird that uh you
know Will Smith was front row and
there's no stage if he was in the fifth
row that'd be a whole different Dynamic
you know if you had to be like oh excuse
me hold on I gotta get down
[Music]
yeah crazy the whole thing's great I'm
just glad you know he uh Chris Rock
didn't make fun of Alec Baldwin's wife
but that could have gotten a little
uglier you know
yeah
all right
I mean that [__] was crazy even Kanye
watched it like oh man that guy's lost
it holy hell yeah
yeah Chris Rock deserves the Oscar for
acting normal you know I got called a
homo once at a college gig I almost
killed myself so oh hey thank you sir
appreciate it hope you didn't Cosby it
all right thank you
I trended on Twitter like that I was I
trended I wasn't even there nothing to
do with me because people are saying
what would what would Ricky Ray's have
said what would what would have happened
to Ricky gervaised well nothing and I
and I said this live I said nothing
would happen to me because I wouldn't
have told
a joke about his wife's hair either told
a joke about her boyfriend
what I would have did if Will Smith
would have smacked me I'd have said I
fell out on the ground and held my face
and said my neck and my back my back and
my neck how to call Larry Parker that
same night
I told him [__] I I woke up look like
hitch the next day oh stop
outside of my face that fail
I got a car in the shop I'm trying to
get out [__] don't hit me
there's a whole lot of white people in
here feel like I'm in court
[Applause]
I got these tight ass leather vanity
pants on
not screaming in these mothers that's
why I'm walking like this on you
just selfishly as a comedian I'm tired
of people putting their own insecurities
or not joke intentions I mean I can't
make a joke about it being cold outside
without somebody yelling back stop
making fun of my small penis
keep my small peace
everybody knows what the [__] happened
everybody that really knows knows I had
nothing to do with that I didn't have
any entanglements and then for people
that don't know what everybody know well
his wife was her son's friend I normally
would not talk about this
but for some reason these put that [__]
on the internet I have no idea why two
talented people would do something that
low down what the everybody in here have
been cheated on none of us have ever
been interviewed by the person that
cheated on us on television none of us
was like Hey I was somebody else's how
did that make you feel
I know this is a special night for you
we uh why don't you have fun we want you
to feel safe and most importantly we
want me to feel safe so we have strict
policies in place if anyone in this
theater commits an act of violence at
any point during the show you will be
awarded the Oscar for best actor
and if any of you get mad at a joke and
decide you want to come up here and get
jiggy with it it's not going to be easy
or a few of my friends are going to have
to get through first you're going to get
have to get through the heavyweight
champ Adonis Creed before you get to me
you're gonna have to do battle with
Michelle yo before you get to me
you are going to have to beat the
Mandalore
for you get
you are gonna have to tangle with
Spider-Man
you are gonna have to
you were gonna have to tangle with Fable
man
look the bottom line is people are
people are without hair you see them all
the time Will Smith's husband
he lost it I hope Will Smith comes back
I like him you know he's coming back
he's got a Slave movie coming out you
know which kind of appropriate for him
because he's used to the backlash but
uh oh yeah well hey what prepares you
more for a Slave movie than being uh
married to Jada Pinkett hey all right
we're getting there the old ball and
chain
okay
[Music]
but that's what's amazing to me is that
rage when you're in when you're in Rage
that's all the Karens will went full
Karen yes he couldn't control it right
there's rage man and rages rage is like
like okay let's talk about the feelings
the best feelings in the world
full rage when you're shaking you feel
like a superhero and you think I will
[__] rip this wall down yeah that
yeah uh being turned on when you're like
oh my God I'm so turned on I could
[__] yeah your body's vibrating
um thank God he didn't feel that toward
Chris that would have been even worse
how great would he be if he's just
[__] just anally raped him on that
stage Jada would have been like finally
that's all she wants but there was rage
it was he was drunk with rage and and
who knows what had happened leading up
to that all the stuff leading up to it
yeah they clearly didn't like they
clearly had tension because yes because
you think about what Rickles used to say
to Sinatra the biggest egomaniac ever
he'd say things like hey Frank make
yourself at home hit someone and Sinatra
would laugh yeah so it's all about past
relationship you know well did you see
the 2016 Oscars where Rock trashes Jada
it's pretty fun it's pretty funny but
it's like oh okay so there is some
history here she was boycotting the
Oscars because will didn't get nominated
and I don't remember the joke but a joke
he goes it's not fairy to get nominee
it's also not fair he got 20 million for
wild wild west and then it was not fair
she goes uh he's like you're not
boycotting you weren't invited I'm not
boycotting Rihanna's panties
I was an edgy joke for the Oscars I know
that's one you probably can't get away
with these days no it was a different
time just 2016 to now is is vastly
different with jaina got mad Jane her
says she's not coming
protesting I'm like it's
Jaden's gonna boycott I said Jada
boycott in the Oscars was like me boy
cotton Rihanna's panties
I wasn't invited
listen you might hear some things you
will stay in your [__] seats
foreign
[Music]
but it's the last physical thing that
people just tease people for hey Baldy
and I give a [__] my friend someone came
up and Polished his head at a party with
a tea towel
[__] terrible [__] it really
devastating devastating so you can't
joke about it anymore and I know what
you're thinking I'm a comedian I should
have a thicker skin than this but no
it's over you cannot knock or tease male
pattern baldness anymore and these are
your rules not [__] mine and I'll
tell you why
I'll tell you why
because one woman once had her baldness
mentioned in jest
and you all lost your [__] [__]
didn't you
[__] Jada Pinkett Smith and her bald ass
[__] head I have zero sympathy I hope
it never grows back
she has it easy
a woman losing their hair is easier than
a man losing their hair and I know you
don't think it is but it [__] is
first of all sympathy out the [__]
wazoo
they get called Brave
sir do
you ever call you Brave
not [__] one no one
she got a water wig she could have worn
a wig no one would have cared men aren't
allowed to cover their baldness up in
any [__] way and if they do they're
considered a loser by Society
if a man has a comb over as soon as he
leaves the room you all make your little
[__] comments
how dare he how dare he try to look like
he has hair like everyone else
not allowed to wear a wig
the man wears a wig and he's found out
that's [__] there's no country you
can move to
if a man weighs a wig he's and he's not
found out his entire life is lived in
fear
all days like this oh for [__] sake
the weatherman said it wouldn't be windy
yet women are allowed to wear wigs
women are allowed to wear wigs over
their full heads of hair
and they're just having a bit of fun
foreign
[Applause]